hey remember when Donald Trump signed
that executive order telling the Army
Corps of Engineers not to delay moving
forward on the Keystone XL pipeline it
was obviously political theater it
wasn't legally binding I made that very
clear at the time but there's something
else another really specific promise
Trump promise that the Keystone XL
pipeline would be made with American
steel he promised this during last
week's presidential address to a joint
session of Congress he actually said
this also when signing the executive
order and he also said it at CPAC let's
take a look at video of Trump saying
this one time this took place while I
was getting ready to sign I said who
makes the bikes for the pipeline well
sir comes from all over the world it's
not wonderful is that nope comes from
the United States oh we're not building
it American steel
if they want a pipeline in the United
States they going to use pipe that's
made in the United States do we agree
pretty clear they're not mincing words
here's another example of when Trump
made clear the pipeline will be built
with American steel thereby creating
tens of thousands of jobs and I've
issued a new direction that new American
pipelines be made with American steel
the project will not be using American
produced steel if it goes forward the
White House has confirmed this White
House spokesperson Sara Huckabee sort of
tried to weasel Trump out of this
promise through a loophole here is a
quote from Sara Huckabee the way that
executive order is written it's specific
to new pipelines or those that are being
repaired since this one is already
currently under construction the steel
is already literally sitting there it
would be hard to go back then why did
Trump same why did Trump say it and I
want to be super super clear here we're
pointing out Trump's lie because it's
one of the 51 lies he told him the 61
minutes of that joint address to
Congress but the Keystone XL pipeline
shouldn't happen no matter where the
steel comes from and I think that if you
are someone who wants the pipeline built
you'd much prefer a media discussion
about where the steel comes from then
about whether the pipeline whether the
pipeline should be built at all I want
to be clear the pipeline shouldn't be
built it makes no sense it creates
almost no permanent jobs it damages the
environment etc but this is yet another
one of trumps verifiable lives also we
should have known this because the world
trade organization requires member
nations to compete fairly on the price
of goods yeah so without changing the
law you can't just go ahead and
exclusively use American steel he should
have known this he was president at the
time he made this yeah and big real
estate developer right i mean if
anything he should know about the rules
around these deals but there's a bigger
hypocrisy here as well which is that
countless Trump business projects were
also made with foreign steel so it's
both a lie and an incredibly
hypocritical demand
it's all falling apart folks I don't
know whether there's anything that's
true about any of what Donald Trump has
been posturing in terms of business
trade deals negotiation etcetera I'm
having a hard time finding anything that
we can believe